hey this is Kim from Khan Academy and
today I'm talking with some experts
about the 4th amendment this is the 4th
amendment of the Bill of Rights and the
4th amendment deals with unreasonable
search and seizure so here's the
official text of the amendment it says
the right of the people to be secure in
their persons houses papers and effects
against unreasonable searches and
seizures shall not be violated and no
warrants shall issue but upon probable
cause supported by oath or affirmation
and particularly describing the place to
be searched and the persons or things to
be seized to learn more about the Fourth
Amendment I talked to two law professors
who specialized in criminal law
professor Tracy Mears of Yale University
and Professor Orin Kerr of George
Washington University and he's a
particular expert in Criminal Procedure
and computer crime
professor Kerr can you tell us a little
bit about what the Fourth Amendment is
and why the framers were interested in
protecting these rights in particular
the Fourth Amendment is a ban on
unreasonable searches and seizures by
the government it's something the
framers were interested in because they
wanted to limit the government's power
at the time of the framing the English
King had engaged in some pretty bad
things that the framers wanted to stop
and one of those was raiding people's
homes with what was called a general
warrant general warrant is basically a
warrant that said the police could go
anywhere and look for anything without
any limit I asked professor Mears to
explain a little bit more about general
warrants she's a professor at Yale Law
School who specializes in Criminal
Procedure and criminal law policy they
were general warrants allowing these
officials to search people's homes
places papers the kinds of things that
the Fourth Amendment lists and ways that
people thought was not okay the Fourth
Amendment was from primarily concerned
with a couple of things one
a case involving seditious libel
investigation it's a case called in tech
and a warrant was issued authorizing in
tech that's the subject of the warrant
his arrest and the seizure of all of his
books and papers so that he could prop
be prosecuted for seditious libel that
case isn't as well-known as the second
case which is called the writs of
assistance case and basically the writs
of assistance involved customs
inspectors who are trying to crack down
on smuggling that was affecting Boston's
economy so to aid in that task
inspectors used writs of assistance that
were issued by the King and authorized
the inspectors both to draft assistance
hence the name writs of assistance and
to search any place where smuggled goods
might be concealed the framers wanted to
put an end to that and so they said no
general warrants are allowed and
searches and seizures have to be
reasonable that really means is the
government can't just stop anyone arrest
anyone break into someone's house there
are limits as to what the government can
do but what are those limits what
determines probable cause for a search
and what renders a search and seizure
unreasonable yeah what counts as
unreasonable is a really big question
there are different answers different
courts have suggested but the basic idea
is that first if the government has a
valid warrant a search or seizure is
reasonable if the warrant if a judge has
signed off and said yeah the government
has probable cause to search this place
for particular evidence then the
government can do that and then the
Supreme Court has laid out a bunch of
what they call exceptions to the warrant
requirement which are also reasonable
searches so for example if a person
consents to a search that's reasonable
or in the case of a car a car can be
searched without a warrant based on
probable cause that's called the
automobile exception there are rules
that govern when the police can stop
somebody temporarily when the government
needs an
arrest they need probable cause they're
basically all sorts of rules that the
Supreme Court has laid out on a bunch of
different cases that say what counts is
an unreasonable search or seizure the
Supreme Court has said that probable
cause means a fair probability that
evidence will be found in a particular
place or that a particular person
committed a crime so fair probability is
is the language now that's not something
the Supreme Court has said you know
that's not 50 percent that doesn't mean
it's more probable than not it just
means like there's pretty good reason to
think that there's evidence to be in a
particular place or at a particular
person committed a crime so it doesn't
mean a hunch it doesn't mean the officer
just had the idea pop into his head but
it also doesn't mean that the officers
certain it's just there's just gotta be
a pretty good reason but not certainty
to think that that person committed the
crime or there's evidence there but when
I asked professor Mears the same
question she wasn't convinced it was so
easy to tell what counts as probable
cause so what counts as a true probable
cause to issue a warrant upon take a
second I mean I taught this today you
can't these aren't questions that you
can just simply answer no one can
actually I mean there is I mean
literally I taught today the fact that
there is no real law on what probable
cause is it's an apparently a factual
determination so how does this work in
practice I asked professor Kerr if it's
the case that a police officer has to
convince a judge that there's probable
cause to issue a warrant yeah so it can
come up in two ways in some cases the
Supreme Court says that the police have
to go to a judge first and get a warrant
and then they have to convince the judge
that what they're about to do is based
on probable cause and in other cases
come up when the government has searched
first or arrested first and then they
come back with the evidence or come back
with the person who was arrested and
then there's a hearing as to whether
there was probable cause for the arrest
that already occurred so either way the
standards are the same it's that fair
probability idea ultimately up to a
judge whether the police were right or
wrong in doing what they did
interesting so there is a little bit of
prior legwork involved in some cases
what happens in cases when it might be
really important to get evidence say if
there's a bomb threat so there are some
rules that are allow searches or
seizures without a warrant call under
what they call exigent circumstances
that basically means there was an
emergency
so the government had to act without a
search warrant and so if there's a
ticking time bomb that they think is
gonna go off in a package and they've
got good reason to think there is this
ticking time bomb in the package they
don't have to say hey we're gonna go
find a judge because by the time they do
that the bomb might have gone off they
can they can search that package under
under this exigent circumstances idea so
that's that's an exception to the rules
although beyond that the there's no
difference between a serious case and a
less serious case under the Fourth
Amendment they're kind of all serious
cases so so the courts have to follow
and the police have to follow same rules
and less serious and more serious cases
professor Mears gave me an example of
what seemed like a less serious case but
it's still a really interesting example
of what counts as an unreasonable search
and seizure I'll give you one more case
that I'm sure the high school students
would love and my students love it it's
a case where a person was sitting in a
noodle shop in front of a window eating
a big bowl of noodles clear soup with
noodles and a police officer walks by
the person eating the noodles and
notices something floating in the bowl
of noodles so he enters into the store
where the person is eating the noodles
and the person is left temporarily the
bowl of noodles to get a napkin or go to
the bathroom or something you know
and the police officer approaches the
bowl picks up the person's spoon and
stirs the noodles to see if he can find
anything and some baggies of crack float
to the top did the person have a
reasonable expectation of privacy in
their food in their soup in their soup
how did they rule they ruled that the
stirring was a search so if it is a
search an ie that you have a subjective
interest in privacy in your soup that
society is prepared to recognize as
reasonable then the police officer would
have to get a warrant before stirring
the soup this raises the question where
do I have Fourth Amendment rights are
some locations protected and not others
the building block of the Fourth
Amendment is really that you have Fourth
Amendment rights in your home in your
pockets in your packages but you don't
have Fourth Amendment rights outside you
don't have Fourth Amendment rights and
what you're doing outside or if the
police want to walk on what they call
open field you know have public streets
that's that you don't have Fourth
Amendment rights in that so thinking
about how the Fourth Amendment applies
just in the physical world if the police
want to break into your home they need a
search warrant
if the police want to watch you walk
down the street they don't need anything
it's not a search or seizure so they can
they can do anything they want just
watching you if they want to arrest you
they need probable cause to believe
you've committed a crime so those are
really the building blocks of the Fourth
Amendment that Gogi of going back to
18th century technology and then the big
question becomes all right well how do
you update that to a modern world it's
also the case that the Fourth Amendment
applies to seizures you know what police
have to show before they arrest a person
or temporarily stop them or you know
briefly Pat their body on the outside of
their body for weapons all of those
questions are Fourth Amendment questions
as are questions involving how much
force police actually use to affect the
arrest once we've decided that an arrest
is legitimate so yeah we haven't talked
about any of those questions but the
Fourth Amendment governs all of that and
remember the Fourth Amendment governs
all of those topics in a context in
which the framers mode of
patience for enacting the Fourth
Amendment have absolutely nothing to do
with most of those things I just
mentioned but the Fourth Amendment also
has implications that go beyond warrants
and seizures
professor Mears thinks that one of the
biggest Fourth Amendment issues today is
discretion
many people have got much more about how
the Fourth Amendment protects privacy
then how the fourth amendment addresses
discretion and by discretion in this
case you mean what they get to decide to
do on their own right exactly so and one
way to see the difference between those
two things is to think about a metal
detector in an airport so long as
everyone is required to go through the
metal detector there is no law
enforcement discretion involved so this
is kind of where the public safety
aspect comes in that if we're all
subject to non-invasive procedures at
the whim of police it's a little
different than if individuals are kind
of plucked for that reason right that
that it's just pointing out that
targeting the targeting of people for
invasions is a different problem than
the invasion problem itself right and so
if all we ever do is thinking think
about privacy invasion without thinking
about the discretion problem then we're
missing something important for
professor Kerr however the most
important issue at stake today regarding
the Fourth Amendment is how it will
apply to electronic media well the big
question I think is how the Fourth
Amendment is going to apply to searches
and seizures of computers of
emails the internet new technologies
that we all use every day we wake up in
the morning and hop online or go on
Twitter or whatever that whatever you
use online lots and lots of
communications online all around the
world and how does the Fourth Amendment
apply to that is something that the
courts are big
to answer but they've only started to
answer some really really hard questions
of kind of translating that physical
world concept of the Fourth Amendment to
the world of computers that we live
today so as we've learned the Fourth
Amendment ensures that government
authorities can trade homes pockets or
papers without a warrant issued by a
judge and then only if there's a
probable cause to believe there's reason
for a search what's tricky is deciding
what counts as probable cause and
whether it's discriminatory to select
some people to search but not others and
how do we translate the Fourth Amendment
to a world where our papers are all
digital should the police be permitted
to search our cell phones our browsing
histories or private social media
profiles you can learn more about the
Fourth Amendment by checking out the
National Constitution Center's
interactive Constitution and Khan
Academy's resources on US government and
politics